Let's suppose that we have a three node network with the costs on the edges as
shown. Initially, each node has a single distance
vector representing the shortest path cost to each other
incident node in the graph. For example, the
distance between x and x is obviously zero.
And the shortest known distance between x and
y, from x's perspective is one, the direct path.
Similarly, the shortest known distance between x and z
to x at the outset is five because all
it knows is the direct path. Note that a
shorter path between x and z exists via y,
but x simply doesn't know about it yet. Now
in distance vector routing, every node send its vectors
to every other adjacent node. And each node then
updates its routing table according to the Bellman-Ford equation.
Let's look at what happens when node x learns of y's distance vectors. Well in
this case, the distance from x to z will be computed as the minimum of the
sums of all distances to z through any
intermediate node. So the cost between x and
y is one, and the distance between y and z as discovered by y's distance vector
is two. Therefore, x can update its shortest
cost distance to z as three. Similarly, x
will receive a distance vector from z, five
two zero, but of course, when it uses
the Bellman-Ford equation to update its distances, again
the distance between z and x will be
updated from five to three. We can repeat
this exercise at other nodes, as they receive distance
vectors from other nodes in the topology. And quickly, every
node in the network has a complete routing table. Now
when costs decrease, the network converges quickly but one problem
is that when failures occurs, bad news can actually travel slowly.